oh god no oh no oh someone should have
done something
Oh mr. Preiser yeah ah [ __ ] hey JD Gabe
oh I almost did my job
Peppadew burb doom but but but what
little bit back mr. Preiser for mr.
president
middle [ __ ] I [ __ ] it oh oh whoops Hey
I said your goddamn wife yeah hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to mr. president
ah I was uh I was extremely ineffective
there mister rump so in this game you're
a bodyguard to mister rump here [ __ ]
I'm coming mr. president oh my god
oh no he's dead no he's dead
I just gotta get his hair oh good yeah
oh oh Jesus
hey he'll hell yeah Oh God
yeah yeah yeah I'm coming for you I'm
coming mr. president I'll save you ha
you're saved I saved you you're I'm the
best catch the bullet ah [ __ ] I didn't
get a chance to do nothing Wow got it
yeah you're welcome rump you're welcome
ah come here mr. president
where's my presidential room okay
goodbye now I guess we're done here [ __ ]
off break the wall ha oh oh my god ah
well I guess I'm supposed to go oh my
god sue I got sued you're welcome you
all them sir
you're welcome sir what is good huh
that's good oh this is where it all
started is it and what's the next one
self-funded presidential run hits a
detour do I have anything else in my oh
oh hello Oh whoo what did I do
I don't know I think I had a mini-game
romp used to be a character in
professional wrestling
now I wants to relive his glory days it
needs your help to feel alive again
the progress you need to drop an elbow
headbutt or head butt on rump how do I
do that
ah [ __ ] whoa your uh-oh oh god oh god I
don't I don't know what's worse the face
the ABS or the thong
oh you're gonna get it mr. rump Oh
I think I smashed the table at half with
my dick that is that's not right then
that shouldn't be that shouldn't exist
that's like a that's a character made in
Dark Souls that never should have made
it past the first stage never should
have been brought back to life that one
oh I call that one the meat grinder
[ __ ] mr. Roy
um I'll just go for the cash bucket
don't mind me yeah yeah where am I now
oh [ __ ] dude ah come on get up oh my
president needs me
Oh God oh uh what uh uh I'm coming back
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I'd sure oh oh geez
oh ah doesn't faze me I'm amazing but uh
ooh ah get out here oh [ __ ] ow he might
be okay
Oh unharmed baby good rum rum rum rum
please rub rub rub rub rub rub rub for
you
Rumpy oh all right for his dick Oh God
oh I don't think I saved him oh that was
very close to his luscious hair all
right everybody stop everybody stop
everybody done hey hey timeout here I
just found out through the horn on the
horn in my horn I found out in my horn
that this guy's name is dick rock-hard
Johnson okay everybody get back to it
all right get back to her okay everybody
shows shows not over Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah
goddamn I can have to do it again oh I
like that way better than the actual
game this is so good oh [ __ ] dude oh
[ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude
dick rock-hard Johnson's coming in for
the kill
[Applause]
we're like the sweet tender embrace game
[ __ ] oh you can't
oh I call this the pelvic floor slam
escape me holy [ __ ]
I didn't know that you'd look even worse
from the backside mr. rum oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] dude
Oh oh [ __ ] dude oh oh what's that smell
is that something on the horizon it's an
elusive romp oh [ __ ]
hang on I'm picking up something again
ah I think my sniffer is broken her beta
boosts key whoa careful
that's not huh that's that's daddy
how that works yeah here what how how do
you expect me to believe that's how
that's gonna work that is in them yeah
hands in oh snap into a slim jim yeah Oh
dicks coming for you baby
Oh dicks coming for you baby hold dicks
coming for you baby
okay ah ah [ __ ] did who this time Oh
last time was just a warm-up for dick
baby hold dick rock-hard Johnson come
before
Little Miss Muffet sat on a tuffet yeah
oh yeah oh boy
I was actually like that was actually
like really cool I liked the wrestling
way more than I actually liked The
Bodyguard game of it uh and I was like
legitimately a lot of fun and I hope you
guys enjoyed the video too it should go
without saying this is a silly little
game don't take anything into seriously
but either way I hope you liked it I had
a lot of fun it costs five dollars on
Steam I don't know if that's worth it
but if it is a little link in the
description but thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]